[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم وقع الرئيس الروسي
لازم يفوت المرسومه الرئاستيا بتدابيره
خاصه على فرض دول مجموعه السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي سقفا لاسعار النفط الروسي يحضر
المرسوم تصدير النفط ومنتجاته من روسيا
الى الدول والجهات التي حددت سقفا سعريا
ويدخل المرسوم حيز التنفيذ اعتبارا من
الاول من فبراير ويضل ساريا حتى الاول من
يوليو المقبل
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لبحث القضايا الامنيه في اوكرانيا وغيرها
من القضايا الاستراتيجيه الكبرى واشدد له
على انه لا يمكن التواصل مع اداره الا اذا
ادركت واشنطن سلبيه سلوكها الحاليه وانه
لا بدائل لبناء علاقات الاحترام المتبادل
مع روسيا في اوكرانيا
ورد انا على اقتراح كيف اجراء محادثات
سلاما مع موسكو برعايه الامم المتحده قالت
المتحدثه باسم المنظمات الدوليه انه لا
يمكن للامن العام انطونيو بوترش التوسط
بشان اوكرانيا الا اذا وافقت جميع الاطراف
على ذلك اتهم رئيس الصربي الكسندر فوتشيتش
الغرب
والبنكوسف بالتامر لاستهداف السكان الصرب
في قصبه وامر بوضع قوات الجيش في حاله
تاهب القصوى في المقابل قال وزير الداخليه
في قصور ناصر صربيا تسعه الى زعزعه
استقرار بلاده بدعمها الاقل الصبيه وذلك
بتاثير من روسيا واقام محتجون صرب في
مدينه مترو فيتشال منقسمه عراقيه شمالي
قصه حواجز جديده على الطرق والسما خوف من
تصاعد العنف في الشمال البلاد
نقلت رويترز عن تقارير لوسائل الاعلام
الرسميه في كوريا الشماليه ان زعيم البلاد
كيم جونغ اون كشف عن اهداف جديده للجيش
لعام 2023 في اجتماع حزب العمال الحاكم
المنعقد في الوقت الراهن واضافت التقارير
ان كيم جونغ اون حدد اهداف اساسيه جديده
لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه الذاتيه استعدادا
لتقلبات المتنوعه في الوضع السياسي دون
الكشف عن تفاصيل واطلقت كوريا الشماليه
عددا غير مسبوق من الصواريخ هذا العام وتم
تصميم العديد من عمليات الاطلاق لتطوير
اسلحه الاستراتيجيه بموجب خطه مدتها خمس
سنوات وضعها في مؤتمر حزب العمال في اوائل
عام 2001 و20
ارتفع عدد ضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه التي
تضرب الولايات المتحده الى 63 قتيلا
معظمهم في منطقه بوفالوبي ولايه نيويورك
وبلغ عدد القتلى في ولايه نيويورك وحدها
35 شخصا وذكرت وكاله رويترز ان شركه
الطيران الامريكيه وصلت الغاء رحلتها بسبب
العواصف
الى اللقاء